listen I want to start with and I mean
this sincerely I'm a really big fan of
both of your work and I just want to
thank you for everything that you've
done to making movies and entertaining
me and the whole plan thanks man thank
you um so I am curious though if someone
has never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why okay but hold on
let's get this straight yes is it we
want them to see a movie that is just
going to entertain them and we want them
to see a great movie or do we want them
to see something that we think says more
about yeah
well you see that's the thing say
there's like a 12 year old who has not
seen anything you've done or a 20 year
old 12 year olds aren't allowed to see
the films I mean none of them none of
them but you know what I mean is there
one is there one movie or project that
you've done that really that I don't
know you want people I don't know I I'm
I'm you mean like putting in your time
capsule right the film you put in
listen that's the problem with your both
of your resumes are too um amazing uh to
pick one thing so maybe it's tough I
don't know I'm just you know what I mean
though like I uh for me it would be a
good night and good luck because I wrote
Oh yes that's well chosen yes and it was
about something that was important to me
and it was a it was a tip of my hat to
my father
so all those things I think for that
reason you know not for my acting part
because I didn't have much to do with it
but you know that for me was the one
that I that's a good choice I'm gonna
say Pulp Fiction it might be obvious
might be yeah I know that's probably
what George was thinking I was going to
say and then I said it I I did think
your performance in that was spectacular
almost unrecognizable as me really
honestly the way you danced yeah
yeah wow not to brag speaking of dancing
I I know you've talked about the dance
in this a lot but I am curious
um what is it like because you're I
really like the beer pong sequence and
everything that went into that but what
is it like before you're stepping on set
thinking about a scene like that where
you need to play Drunk you need to be
having fun on camera are you you know
like how are you getting ready before
you start I'm a method actor you know
and I spent time I just thought about
all the times that George and I have sat
around drunk laughing dancing and
thought I know what that was like no
we've been prepping for this movie for
20 years
by the way uh I was very good at the
beer pong yes I was very good because
they were they brought in like guys to
like throw the and I was like dude what
what let the master do it yes you know
I'll ask you a different question then
say on a Monday morning you have a
really emotional scene or something very
dramatic something that you know you
really got to dig inside to pull it out
to deliver it on on set how early on
before Monday are you thinking about
that scene and preparing for it in our
and do you save the emotion for the day
or are you like sort of getting that
ready prior to stepping on set okay so
what do you do do you prepare I am gonna
say I think about it a lot
um but I don't I wouldn't say that I
prepare emotionally as it were until the
day
until the day yeah yeah I think the
secret is always specifically to know to
really have your lines down pat because
you don't want to be
searching for that and then everything
else I think because you know that's why
rehearsals sometimes are so don't work
uh is because you can be rehearsing here
a lot of times you'll come to a hotel
room and rehearse the scene we would
talk about this on other projects we've
done and and all of the elements that
you have when you're doing it here once
you get on a set with different with the
real actors with the real set and with
everything else going on it can be
completely different and so oftentimes
it's about understanding the basics and
then getting into the room and letting
uh whatever happens happen on that note
I need to go I'm just going to say again
thank you so much for entertaining me
for so long
um and I hope it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you